I'm very pleased to be invited to this
forum to talk about my experience on
becoming a scientist and an educator my
name is Robert Ramirez and I'm a
professor of microbiology at San
Francisco State University so what are
the lessons that I learned and that I
hope to share in this presentation I
hope to remind you that with persistence
and motivation a career in science and
education is open to anyone but success
also depends on possessing a variety of
skills first of all you should study
each challenge very carefully you should
get as much information as possible you
should make very critical decisions you
should develop a good gut instinct and
you should be independent and not
surprisingly many of these skills are
necessary to practice good science I was
born in the small agricultural town in
Northern California I had a very happy
childhood of running in the fields and
climbing the trees behind my house my
mom was a homemaker she was born here in
the United States and graduated from
high school my father on the other hand
was a Mexican national he was also
illiterate he could not read or write in
Spanish or in English consequently my
father had to take jobs working in the
fields this resulted in a very low
income in our household and we were for
lack of a better word very poor there in
addition there was no tradition of
education in my family and this wasn't
because of any negative association with
education it was just simply because my
parents didn't know anything about it
for economic reasons my father decided
to move my
to Mexico where he could secure a better
living the town that he moved us to was
a very small rural town that lacked many
services including a high school so at
the root so at the age of 14 my
education came to a stop for four years
I worked on the family ranch and finally
I decided you know this isn't very good
and I decided to return to the United
States once here in the United States I
got my GED diploma and I started
attending a community college I started
to take every course that I could find
that had the word basic inning basic
mathematics basic English basic
chemistry eventually after four years of
study my advisor told me that it was
time for me to transfer to a four-year
university to get a bachelor's degree
and I was quite honestly surprised that
I was even allowed to do that I
transferred to the University of
California at Riverside and those were
the two happiest years of my life I met
people who became lifelong friends and I
took a variety of different courses I
took Shakespeare in art history as well
as physical chemistry and human
embryology it was everything that Ruth
Simmons the president of Brown
University said a university should be
she said that a university should
provide a profession it should provide a
philosophy of life it should provide
independence and it should provide an
awareness of the world and the education
that I got at the University of
California Riverside did all of these
things for me after I graduated one of
my professors offered me a job in her
lab and I did research for four years it
was there that I learned the precision
of science
afterwards I then attended the
University of California Davis where I
pursued my doctoral degree in
microbiology I then did my postdoctoral
research
at the University of California in San
Francisco and at Lawrence Berkeley
Laboratory during my professional
development I was fortunate to have met
several excellent mentors the first was
dr. Catherine Atkinson at the University
of California Riverside
the second was dr. Myrna Viejo and at
the University of California Davis and
lastly dr. Michael Esposito at Lawrence
Berkeley Laboratory in 1993 I was hired
to teach at San Francisco State
University
eventually I received tenure and I was
promoted to full professor at San
Francisco State University I teach
various senior level courses in
microbiology and in virology I also do
research and I use these to study stress
responses and lipid metabolism at symfon
San Francisco State University I work
with a wonderful diverse set of
colleagues of the forty professors in
the biology department eight are
underrepresented minorities and five are
gay or lesbian our country in our world
needs an educated diverse and well
informed society but we also face many
challenges right now we are in the midst
of a severe economic crisis that makes
the pursuit of an education much more
difficult but we also find ourselves in
a society that is increasingly
intolerant of minorities and people of
color
I find this especially upsetting because
I am a minority and I'm gay if these
negative influences are allowed to
escalate we will find ourselves without
people like Ruth Simmons the first
African American woman president of an
Ivy League university without African
Unity no Xhosa a noted neurosurgeon or
without people like louise vrl an
eminent virologist we need to recognize
that we need to involve all members of
our society for our common good
we need to recognize
the unique gift that each one of us
possess thank you
you